hi good morning my name is Biffen
Kulkarni and I welcome you to the video
on how to become a cyber security expert
in this video of you are going to
discuss the various domains in cyber
security we are going to look at the
certifications available and you're
going to try to map them up with the job
rules that are available in the security
space today so what's in it for you we
start off with the baseline on what is
the qualification required to enter this
field we then look at the various
domains in cyber security the
foundational cyber security courses from
there you can begin your career the
manager of cyber security courses which
would be utilized by people in a
managerial position some advanced cyber
security courses and then the job roles
that are available in cyber security
let's start off with educational
qualifications first so as far as
educational qualification is concerned
having a graduate degree in computer
science or IT security or related field
is given having a master's program or a
master's degree is an added advantage
there are a lot of universities out
there in today's world that offer both
bachelor's and master's degrees in cyber
security or various computer fields you
might want to look them up before you
decide which university what do you want
to go with are there private Institute's
like ec-council sands or country arc
that offer these kind of programs as
well the costs vary some of them are
correspondence some of them are physical
in nature so let's talk about the skills
that you're required to become a cyber
security expert or an engineer these are
your baseline skills it will be very
important that you have some of the
knowledge out of all of these tasks it
may not be necessary that you have
everything at at the start itself but it
will help you if you start building on
these technologies before you start
looking at advanced certifications so
you need to have solid ground in IT
fundamentals which means that you need
to understand computers you need to
understand how the function the
components of a computer may be what's a
processor what is a cache a basically
understanding the hardware part of it
right then solid ground in networking
fundamentals are you
hackers normally target the network you
want to hack over the Internet you want
to hack
or the intranet there are a lot of
protocols that are required and I
utilize for data to be transmitted from
one point to another there are a lot of
routing protocols of how a data packet
can be converted from a internal IP
address to an external IP address how
that packet is going to take a path to
the end point and how was it going to
travel back to your machine and how your
machine and the end point machine are
going to interact with each other so
having a good understanding of
networking and how computers function
over the intranet and the Internet is a
very much required knowledge base coding
skills now as far as schooling is
concerned you are not going to develop
applications over here but some
scripting skills would be necessary
especially if you are going into network
security and host-based security for
example you want to write it your write
your own exploit in various tools like
Metasploit so you might want to learn
languages like Ruby however if you're
going to go into application security
then knowing Java or joy knowing C++
those kind of languages is a must you
may not be able to write complex
programs but you need to understand how
those functions are being called you
need to know standard secure coding
practices that that need to be utilized
for an application to be secure then
understanding the architecture of an
operating system it is imperative that
we know how operating systems function
and not function from a usability
perspective but from a troubleshooting
perspective we need to understand if
there's an error on the operating system
how do we troubleshoot that we need to
understand how processes work in the
background how memory mapping works in
the background what web application
pools are being utilized and the various
protocols that are being consumed by the
operating system now cloud Security's a
very niche skill in today's world but
cloud as we all know is here to stay and
most of the organizations that you'll
deal with will either have a private
cloud or public cloud or a hybrid cloud
so it is imperative that you upscale
yourself understanding how cloud
technologies work how they can be
integrated in your day to day
infrastructure and how you can secure a
cloud now this doesn't become a baseline
requirement obviously you'll need to
grow and you'll need to build based on
the expertise that you have but over a
period of time it would benefit you to
have cloud security knowledge and then
malware analysis and reversing when
you're talking about cyber
security one of the most common attacks
that we'll see would be from a virus or
a Trojan so understanding how these
software's book how to identify them how
to troubleshoot them how to
reverse-engineer them and analyze these
malware's becomes important again this
may not be a baseline requirement but
you need to cool on your skills on
understanding malware and reverse
engineering them especially if you're
going into a malware analysis kind of a
rule let's start with the domains in
cyber security let's understand what
kind of domains are available and how we
can map them as we go ahead with
certifications and our job rules so
starting with the domains in cyber
security
there is access control systems and
methodologies telecommunications and
network security security management and
practices access controls control
systems and methodologies would talk
about Identity and Access Management
single sign-on
Federation so basically designing access
controls identifying the people who are
trying to log in authenticating them and
then authorizing them to access some
resources that are there in your
organization so we're basically talking
about the I Triple A standards over here
identification authorization
authentication and accountability then
there's telecommunications and network
security so you start up here with
certifications like CCNA ccnp where you
are talking about communications and
protocols that work on the intranet and
the internet so how to secure these
protocols how to deploy these protocols
to start off with how to configure
switches routers and how to secure them
so that data leakages or attacks on your
networks can be minimized then we have
security management practices which
basically deal with disaster recovery
and business continuity planning so here
you're planning about system failures
because of various attacks like a
distributed denial of service or a virus
or a ransomware attack or even
environmental attacks like natural
disasters like fires or flooding and
man-made disasters where people cannot
show up to work and you have to ensure
that your business continuity is not
affected because any of these factors
security architectures and models so
this donal focuses mostly on having
security policies and procedures so here
you are more on a managerial perspective
or you're creating policies to be
implemented in your organization's
policies are nothing but high-level
standards which you need to implement
for example what level of encryption you
want do you want to use a policy would
it include things like data
classification so you're identifying
data and you're classifying them based
on the sensitivity of that data towards
your organization for example some of
that data could be classified some of
them could be secret top secret and some
data could be unclassified so these
policies help you identify and decide
how you're going to treat security in
your organization then we have law
investigation and ethics
so this domain can be mapped with the
forensic investigations so for example a
crime has happened somebody has got
compromised some data has been
compromised you as a forensic
investigator come in and try to analyze
what went wrong you try to analyze what
has been affected to what extent has
been affected how did that hack happen
then application and system development
security now this is where you are
talking about application security so
let's say you go into a software
development lifecycle you are developing
an application and you want to treat
that application with security in mind
so you're asked top ten open web
application security project comes in
you look at the top ten risks like
injection attacks
maybe cross-site scripting cross-site
request forgery and you try to mitigate
these attacks by following secure coding
practices testing the application from
security perspective and ensuring that
your coding is strong enough to
withstand such attacks cryptography so
this is where you go into the encryption
phase where you are going to try to
create solutions on how which kind of
encryptions you want to utilize to
protect which kind of data if you
remember earlier on we talked about
policies where you did data
classification where some data's
sensitive some data is classified
top-secret and those different various
classifications now to keep costs at bay
you cannot use the same encryption
across because what you're using for
confidential information or secret
information would be a very high level
encryption which would cost you a lot of
money to implement so in cryptography
it's basically you becoming an expert in
understanding which kind of encryption
standards you want to implement on what
kind of data or what kind of solutions
you want to integrate on an
organizational level so here you'll be
looking at data in use
when data is being consumed by a user
data in motion when it's being
transmitted
for example the HTTP connection that we
have with websites or data in rest when
data is being stored on to a stationary
hard disk and you want to encrypt that
then you have the computer operation
security so this would be covering your
day-to-day security operations so
something that we call a sock a security
operation center where you're going to
look at all the various incidents that
happen on a regular basis you're going
to investigate those incidents and
you're going to see if they are going to
affect our your organization security in
any which map in any which manner and
then trying to come up with a solution
to prevent that from happening and the
final part is physical security now this
does look like it it may not cover IT
security but it does for example your
dues that you're going to place to
sensitive areas for example a server who
you do not want anyone and everyone
access to that server room so what kind
of security are you going to use to
secure that server room for example CCTV
cameras or biometrics on your doors so
what kind of those do you want there in
the first place do you want to keep
security guards over there and they're
going to frisk people to see if they are
having anything that can be used to
manipulate the security of the servers
moving on from the domains let's start
with the foundational cyber security
courses now the first four that are
populating the screen CH security plus
certified network defender and the
forensic investigator now they are
mapped as foundational cyber security
courses but in their own right there
still advanced courses because if you
see they do assume that have some
knowledge on scripting you may have some
basic knowledge on operating systems but
you are technically adept at analyzing
problems so they do assume a little bit
of knowledge from your side if your
refresher you want to hone up a little
bit on your networking skills you want
to hone up a little bit on how operating
systems work and how their processes
work and then you want to attempt these
certifications the first one being
certified network defender now this is a
certificate that talks about network
security CH on the other hand talks
about an ethical hacker from offensive
security perspective where you are doing
a penetration test and you're going to
try to leverage attacks against an
organization to analyze how their
security is come to your security plus
all
so is on the same lines of ch ch is
offered by an organization called
ec-council the competitor to them is
come Chia both of them are globally
accepted certifications widely accepted
across the Americas Europe and Asia the
CH fi which is the computer hacking
forensic investigator certification is
basically the English certification for
forensic investigators you can directly
attempt the CH fi but if you don't know
how hackers work it made the fit some of
the purpose so it would help to first go
for the CH or the security plus and then
the Safari SEC investigator
certification let's look at a brief
overview on each of these to start off
with the CH it is going to train you in
reverse engineering
so this is where penetration testers
come in and the word ethical hackers
hackers are basically people who try to
hit unauthorized access to various
resources ethical hacker is where you're
going to emulate assignment those
attacks with an authorization from the
organisation so you still keep it legal
the aim is to find out various flaws in
the current deployment of security
controls and then try to figure out how
you can plug those flaws and increase or
improve on the security posture so it's
a CH and computer security plus are
about the same it's just the difference
of the certification body but both of
these are widely accepted and globally
accepted as well then we have the
certified network defender covers
protection identification in response to
on how we approach network security so
this is the certification that is going
to explain you certain protocols you're
going to talk about switches routers
videos or technologies of land man man
and you're going to talk about how we
can secure networks on an organizational
perspective the foreign seek
investigator certification as we've
discussed is in the domain of law
investigation and ethics it talks more
about analyzing how the attack happened
what was affected what was compromised
to what extent and then we are trying to
reverse engineer and try to identify the
culprit of who attacked that
organization after the foundational view
going to look at the managerial
cybersecurity courses now here you are
either a cybersecurity manager or you're
looking at a lead kind of a scenario
where you are responsible to manage the
team who's going to implement security
in your organization
friends here is the previous courses are
very technical in nature very hands-on
in nature and you are the person who is
going to be responsible to implement
that security control or test that
security control here in managerial
cybersecurity courses you are not going
to be technical hands-on but you're
going to be more on the policy side of
things so start off with Co bit Co bit
stock talks about control objectives for
information and related technologies now
this is an advanced kind of a
certification then you have a CIS sim
some people call its system as well
it's the certified information security
manager certification then we have CSR
or si is a certified information systems
auditor and then we have the CR is C
which is a certified in risk and
information systems control so as you
can see just from the names
nothing hands-on no penetration testing
no vulnerability assessments no
implementation of tools but you're going
to have a holistic view of how well
abilities and threats are going to
affect the organisation and you will be
responsible to manage and guide the team
on what to be implemented and what to be
consumed so you will be managing teams
technical teams on how to implement
security and how to analyze that
security you will try to make sense of
data that has been provided to you and
utilize that data to make business sense
so what is Co bit it gives you a deep
understanding of the framework for
managing and governing enterprise IT
environments so it's all about the
environment now in an enterprise
organization this is a standard so it
gives you a basic framework of how you
want to implement security from an
end-to-end perspective you're going to
talk about IT governance here you're
going to deal with a lot of stakeholders
over here you're going to hear a lot of
various inputs and you're going to
analyze that information and you're
going to implement the framework based
on the analysis that you have done
people with corporate certifications and
who've been hired as managers would
normally have around 8 9 years of
experience and only then would they be
put in such a position CISM the security
manager certification it is a key
certification for information security
professionals who manage design oversee
and assess Enterprise Information
Security so this is more from a project
management perspective but projects
regarding security so it is a semi
technical certification it is
you understand the technical terms of
hacking or ethical hacking you have a
basic understanding of what kind of
risks or attacks are present in a
cybersecurity enterprise and then you're
going to manage the project and try to
implement security and analyze that
security to see everything needs
standards so as far as a security
manager is concerned since we are
talking about the manager portfolio you
obviously will have to have some
experience before you get these kind of
job rules then comes the seesaw or the
CISA the systems on it up it will give
you the skillsets to govern and control
enterprise IT can perform an effective
security audit on any organization so
this is more of an system or it does
profile where you're going to talk about
overall functioning of IT infrastructure
in an organization you're going to audit
that infrastructure to ensure that it
meets standards and you're going to look
at the risks that the that are going to
affect this infrastructure you're going
to do a risk management exercise and
then you're going to come up with
security controls on how to minimize or
mitigate these risks the CR is C the
risk MA there's another risk management
certification but it is widely accepted
and it has a lot of value globally this
course will enable you to design
implement monitor and maintain
information security controls for
enterprises now this certification only
deals with risk management so it has a
complete strategy that evolves and
revolves around risk identification
assessment response and control
monitoring so the major job position
that you're going to have is in an IT
infrastructure identifying the risks or
identifying the identifying this
security risks that the organization is
going to face you're going to assess
them so a business impact analysis if
that risk comes true how is it going to
affect the business not only from a
technical perspective but from a
monetary perspective as well and then
you're going to do a cost-benefit
analysis for a security control for
example I figure out that a web
application has a sequel injection
attack vulnerability if the assessment
proves that if this becomes real or if
this is realized by a hacker we would be
looking at a potential loss of 1 million
dollars and we'll have to report it to
the regulatory authority which would
then lead to further fines so here then
we're going to figure out a response to
this threat where let's say we identify
a Web Application Firewall
and an
addition of that firewall will minimize
the risk at the same time a developer
would come into the picture and say we
can redevelop the application or that
part of the application where the
vulnerability exists and we can ensure
that the application is secure now when
you do a cost-benefit analysis you
figure out that for the recording of
that part of that application would take
at least six months and is going to cost
us a lot of money whereas if we
implement a web application firewall it
will just cost us around $50,000 and we
would still minimize a million dollar
risk now here it does the response will
be of the risk manager to identify which
solution would benefit the organization
in the long run so that's how your cost
benefit analysis comes in and then
you're going to implement the solution
and then you're going to continuously
monitor it to ensure that the rest
doesn't surface again so it depends on
which organization you're talking about
but you I mean you would need at least
three to four years of experience in
risk strategy before you become a risk
manager but these are the certifications
that are going to identify and help you
in your career path as we go ahead now
before we go into cloud computing
courses just one point that I want to
highlight here the first courses that we
talked about with technical in the
second where management in perspective
now even if it is IT security that we
talked about in today's world it is more
on the business side that everyone
starts making sense so for example when
you start talking to the management you
always will talk about it about security
from a monetary perspective and a
business impact analysis perspective so
as we go ahead in IT security career
paths you will always material from a
technical guide to a semi technical guy
to work and then over over a period to
manage your quotient and then probably
the c-level executives like the CIS oh
the CFO of the CTO chief technology
officer so let's start with the next
topic the cloud computing courses as
discussed these are not mandatory but
with today's world where we have
everybody has jumped onto the cloud
computing bandwagon you will want to
expand your horizons and get cloud
security under your belt as well the two
courses on your screen the CCS fee and
the CCS k are vendor-neutral courses and
are more towards the managerial
perspective rather than technical
perspective so the C CSP is the
certificate of
cloud security professional this
certification is given to you by IC
square whereas the ccs k is a
certificate of cloud security knowledge
given to you by an organization called
cloud security alliance CCSP
thus the certificate of cloud security
professionals again has a holistic view
of cloud security they have listed six
different domains in the certification
and IC square has created a common body
of knowledge based on which it will give
you an holistic view of what steps do
you want to look at for various
deployments in a cloud security now this
becomes an advanced certification the
first certification that came across was
the CC escape which is from a body a
nonprofit organization called cloud
security alliance now this is again of a
base examination this one is a little
bit easier to attend than the CCSP
so if you want to enter the cloud
security arena I would suggest you start
with the CCS case certificate and then
move on to C CSP if it is technical that
you have in that you have in mind then
you become vendor specific so either you
go for Amazon Web Services for a public
cloud or Microsoft Azure or if you want
to look at private clouds we've got
VMware certifications and if you've got
Microsoft hyper-v we have got Citrix
certifications so depending on which
vendor of its solution that you want to
deal with you'll have to identify those
vendors and you have to get certified on
those specific technologies each vendor
has their own set of certifications you
can just visit their websites and they
have a career path for their individual
certifications there as well let's talk
about at one cybersecurity courses now
the gold standard in advanced
cybersecurity courses is all obviously
the SIS or the CISSP which is the
certified information systems security
professional so when you're headed for
the management courses are or you going
to look at profiles like the chief
technology officer or the chief
information security officer you're
looking at this particular course this
is a very difficult exam to crack
because you need that experience you
just cannot read books gather knowledge
from those books and pass this exam in
fact you have to prove that you have
five years of experience in two of the
domains that cissp talks about if you
don't you can still attempt the exam but
you get certified as an associate of the
IC square for cissp and you've got six
years to complete
the five-year experienced bracket the
passing rate of that exam is less than
5% so it's a tough exam to crack
currently there are other example ances
of 100 to 150 questions and you have to
answer those in 3 hours now that sounds
like a simple task but the areas that
are covered in this certification are
vast and the knowledge that is required
and the experience that is required is
very high as well
I have seen people game around 15 years
of experience in the ID field and then
attempt the CISSP that being said I have
also seen people with very good
knowledge clear they examine in a couple
of by studying for just a couple of
weeks so it depends on how good you are
how good your knowledge is how good your
experience is how good your
understanding on various topics is and
based on that you can crack this exam
easily as well the domains in CISSP or
as such they start off with asset
security then we have security
architecture and engineering
communications and network security
Identity and Access Management security
operations security assessment and
testing software development security
and security and risk management now we
start off with security and risk
management it talks about again the risk
assessment strategies the risk
assessments life cycles are brisk
calculators and a lot of other
terminology like an annual loss
expectant expectancy a single loss
expectancy etc Asset security will talk
about physical assets or data assets and
how you're going to secure them and the
strategy is revolving that security
architecture and engineering we'll talk
about models security models or
frameworks that will help us create a
policy and administer that policy on our
organization communication and network
obviously we'll talk about network
security different protocols this topic
is all about mapping the OSI layer the
tcp/ip layer understanding which
protocols will not work where and the
various encryption strategies that are
there in securing communications
identity and access management this
talks about access control lists single
sign-on and so on so forth security
operations the day-to-day operations of
a security operation center where you're
going to look at incident management
change management and problem management
security assessment and testing
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing software
main security the software development
lifecycle we're going to talk about
secure coding practices in an
application you're going to talk about
various models that are utilized like
the waterfall model or the agile model
to be implemented for application
security so if you remember some slides
back we were talking about the various
domains in cyber security now if you map
that's those slides with this you will
understand that C is ASP basically
governs everything that works in the IT
security space so it needs a lot of
understanding a lot of knowledge for
this certification so let's talk about
the job roles in cyber security now
every organization will have its own
naming convention and their job titles
so this may really a little bit in the
real world but these are the baseline
job requirements and job functions are
that would be available or that are
required in today's world in
cybersecurity so let's start talking
about these roles so the first one is
chief information and security officer
also known as cecil or CIS oh now this
is a very privileged position and is a
managerial position in the organization
here you own the cybersecurity of the
entire organization and your job role is
to ensure proper policies proper
frameworks and proper standards are
followed in your organization so it's a
very holistic view that you have there's
no hands-on involved you will not be
involved in VAP t but you may actually
ask your team to conduct a vulnerability
assessment and penetration test if needs
requires you just think the reports
analyze them and guide the rest of the
team in how to proceed with those
critical incidents so you start off with
at least a graduate degree in computer
science or an IT security or a master's
that's a given the certifications could
be all of these or any of these a CISSP
is required certificate at this point in
time the systems auditor Systems Manager
or the risk management certification
would obviously help your cause and help
you gain that knowledge that is required
for this particular job rule now since
this is a manager rule the requirement
is also very high you will have to have
at least 15 years of experience before
you reach this position so you already
should have worked in the IT security
field in multiple domains you should
have had these certifications during
this period which would then qualify
you to become a CEO of an organization
your skills obviously would be ethical
hacking no hands-on but you understand
those attacks you know how they have
done you are conversant with how these
technologies work you know the OSI layer
the TCP layer you know networking you
know how attacks can be created and copy
treated computer forensics knowledge of
that would obviously be necessary over
here odd would be an advantage if you
are certified in forensic investigations
because in case of a breach you can
guide the team of where exactly to look
for what kind of data mobile security
for a if your organization has a bring
your own device policy that would help
you understand how to implement security
parameters and how to control data that
is going to leave your organization on
some employees mobile phones an example
here would be employees configuring the
emails on their mobile phones and does
the attachments can be downloaded on
those phones and you want to ensure that
those documents or attachments to not
get compromised cloud security is also
necessary here because most of the
organizations that you will see will be
connected to a cloud or will be
consuming some services from the cloud
for example Salesforce customer
relationship management software's or
office 365 getting integrated with an
in-house domain networking knowledge is
a must the work experience like I said
would be around 15 years minimum and you
should have worked in network security
he should know storages you should have
a basic understanding of how Hardware
works
you should have skills on vendor
management and protection protecting
systems against at once persistent
threats so you should know how idss IPSS
work you should know the latest trends
in the security market and you should
understand which vendors to approach at
what point in time salaries could range
from one hundred thousand USD two
hundred and twenty five thousand or in
India 15 lakh rupees to twenty five lakh
rupees now these are baseline salaries
it will obviously depend on what kind of
an organization you are joining if it's
a start-up your salaries may not be that
high or if it's a global organisations
your salaries could be the more than
what have been projected on the screen
the next rule we can talk about is an
information security analyst now here
again the requirement is that you
understand security from holistic
perspective you're going to collect data
you're going to analyze
data and you're going to interpret that
data based on your knowledge based on
your experience and try to figure out if
there is something wrong or if there is
something dishonest going on in the
organization for example collecting a
data dump of a networking device for a
segment of time and then analyzing the
packets that are going through that
particular segment to see if there are
any background services running any
background data leakage is happening or
it could be as simple as you joining a
Security Operations Center and when an
incident arises you become that security
analyst where you analyze the incident
you try to investigate what has happened
and then you come out with what exactly
has been impacted and then try to find a
resolution for that so your baseline
again is you going to be a graduate in
computer science or an IT security field
masters would always be helpful but here
it is not required a bachelor's degree
is more than sufficient
so the certification that you'll require
here are the Sai surplus which is the
cyber security analysts from comm Chia
and the EC console security analysts
from EC Council now these two
certificates help you understand how you
can collect data what data sources are
available and how to configure them and
how to analyze that data that is what
these courses are all about the CISSP
course again here would be an added
advantage for you to understand how to
convert that data into risk analysis and
then give a business impact analysis to
your manager along with the technical
report so the skills that you are going
to require for this job information
assurance assurance is the part where
you are investigating to ascertain that
the security controls that have been
implemented are working correctly for
example there is a security architect
was identified that a firewall needs to
be placed and there's a configuration
that has been done on the firewall a
security analyst over a period of time
will analyze the effectiveness of that
particular firewall and see if there are
any gaps or if there are any problems
with the device and if it needs any more
fine-tuning you will also need to know a
little bit of scripting languages so
Python it's a scripting language and
when we say line is over here you
obviously talking about the bash
scripting scenario where you can create
your own scripts and use those scripts
to analyze certain scenarios
cryptography again encryption
understanding of encryption how it works
because you're going to
that kind of data so cryptography is a
required skill set network security is a
must across all platforms across all
rules because that's how computers
communicate with each other over the
Internet and the Internet work
experience network architecture so
courses like CCNA ccnp CCIE would be
helpful for you to understand how
network works now this is assuming that
you're using cisco devices for other
devices like juniper there are different
courses from those vendors log
management so understanding how a syslog
server works or how a siem tool works
and utilizing those tools to collect
data and use that data to for further
analysis the salary here could vary from
ninety five thousand two hundred and
twenty three thousand USD or five lakhs
to eighteen lakhs per annum in India
again the salaries are baselines depends
on which organization you're joining
startup may not be able to pay you that
much global organization could pay you a
lot more than what is being showcased
but these are the average salaries
across all job
rolls right so let's talk about the
foreign side computer analyst job
profile so the foreign ce computer
analyst job rule is where your job
description would be to analyze after
attack has been identified or an impact
has been observed in your organization
so this job role would definitely where
be after the attack has happened so you
will be going in and you're going to try
to analyze what got impacted how did
that attack happen which all components
have been affected and if there has been
any data breach so the other rule would
be very you're going to do a reverse
engineering trying to identify who
attacked you IP addresses MAC addresses
or any trace that he can find out that
occur and how exactly did that act take
place what was the validity what was the
exploit and that would give your
knowledge which get passed on to the
security analyst who can then further
try to resolve that particular problem
your certifications would be CHF five
which is a certified hacking for ensuing
investigation certificate that we saw
from EC counsel there are other
certificates in the market as well such
as C f/c e and z CF a the skills are you
going to require here are analytical
skills you're going to analyze a lot of
data now understand the fact that the
attack has happened it has been
identified by some reason and you are
being tasked with the requirement of
identifying what exactly happened what
got
affected and to what extent has been the
damage so you're trying to
reverse-engineer something that has
already happened and you're going to try
to think of how attacker would have
created that but if you're attacked
obviously you'll have to create reports
after that and report writing skills
should be excellent your communication
should be somewhat of a techno managed
real kind of a scenario so you should be
technical you know all the technical
things but you can translate them into
simple English for non-technical people
to understand I want to send the fact
that when you send these reports to the
management the management will have
basic understanding of those keywords
they would not be technically adept of
hacking or off foreign section so your
report writing skills there would be a
huge requirement at this point in time
your communications how you communicate
with your peers how you're going to
communicate your requirements what you
want for that analysis what kind of
tools do you require and when you create
those reports and you're going to
communicate them or you're going to
present them to the management in very
precise manner that's where your
communication skills would be required
and your knowledge on digital storage
devices where you're going to acquire
data and you're going to store that data
for example there may be scenarios where
a law-enforcement agency may come in and
you will have to collect that data in a
manner where you have to store it and
then present it in a court as evidence
later on so here some requirements would
be where you know the law of the land
and you know how to acquire that
evidence how to store that evidence you
know the chain of custody so that he can
present that data in a court of law and
prove that it is still valid data your
work experience you should know your
operating systems how those processes
works where the cachet is how is it
stored how is the data processed so that
you can access those areas of the
operating systems or those applications
and you can extract that data from those
storage areas scripting languages would
be required for you to create or let's
say PowerShell scripts or bash scripts
depending on the operating system and
then automate some tasks for collecting
some data data processing skills because
you're going to collect data you're
going to process that data you're going
to look at processes that are running in
the background so all of that would be
required as a work experience
salary again would vary from sixty nine
thousand two hundred and fourteen
thousand USD and in India around five
lakhs to eighteen lakhs per annum
looking at a security architect's role
so a security architect is a person who
signs and architects security so your
job role would be where let's say
there's a network deployment that's
going to happen and you are being called
in to design a plan on how you want to
implement security on the entire network
or you could be on the cloud and you
want a new deployment on the cloud and
you're caught talking about cloud
security so here you're going to design
how that security is going to function
your job roles would be where you want
to place those firewalls what kind of
firewalls you want to place or what kind
of idss IPSS unified threat management
systems or endpoint antivirus systems
would be required here you would be
looking at security controls and
placement of those security controls in
various scenarios for example what kind
of email filters do you want to create
or what kind of email scanning you want
to implement in your organization to
scan incoming attachments or outgoing
emails another example would be where
you are looking at routing and you're
looking at how data packets are going to
travel across the network and you have
some dedicated paths that you have to
create to ensure that all those packets
go through a firewall a firewall is
configured in a particular manner which
will either allow or disallow that
packet based on the configuration that
you are going to suggest again the
baseline would be graduate in a computer
science or an IT security field here
master's degree would be advisable over
the period of your career right and
again your courses like CH the certified
ethical hacking course or the security
plus or the ECAC CSA course the
ec-council certified security analyst
course would be prescribed cissp is open
across all tables across all job roles
so as you get experience and you've got
at least five years of experience that's
when you try to attempt the CISSP
certification but you start off with CH
then you move on to EC sa security plus
and then that's your career path to
become a security architect again their
experience here would be at least seven
to eight years in IT security to become
a successful security architect and an
organizational level skills operating
systems
application security cloud security
network security you basically you're
going to design the security of an
organization or of a particular product
so you need to know almost anything and
everything there is about information
technology work experience as suggested
seven to eight years is ideal but
anything between
- ten years would be our requirement in
IT security the five to ten years of
experience that we are talking about is
entirely NIT security so you either have
quality management experience or a patch
management experience or your experience
in application security or in the code
security so all of that combined should
be around five to ten years for you to
become a successful security architect
salaries would range from fifty thousand
to a hundred thousand US dollars and six
lakhs to 20 lakhs in India and rupees
then let's talk about ID security
consultant now the main job role of a
consultant is to provide intelligence on
various technologies so here you could
become a business consultant where you
may need to go to the client site check
their requirements come back to your
organization and then detail the team of
the requirements and then map the
solutions that you're going to offer
based on those requirements or a client
needs to implement a security
architecture or needs to implement
security controls you as a consultant
just advise them how it is done what is
required what kind of policies should be
there and then provide that expertise to
them so this is basically more of a
business oriented rule from a security
perspective this is where you have to
know it all so not only technical but
you'll also need to have knowledge on
how businesses function what kind of
security controls are available and
which security controls to position at
what security areas
so again physical security is also in
play you're going to talk about CCTV
cameras you're going to talk about
physical security about server rooms
you're going to talk about this as to
recovery and business continuity
planning
so this basically becomes a consultant's
view of how a business should function
in the long run again the educational
requirement a graduate degree in
computer science or IT security or a
master's degree is advisable at this
point in time cissp CR is C C is M these
are a must like I said these are
advanced certifications and this is an
advanced job profile as well so assuming
you have C is a speed or that already
assumes that you probably would have
done your CH or security plus or sighs
uh plus and those certifications earlier
on in your career path your programming
skills again you shouldn't be a
developer that's not a requirement but
you shouldn't understand programming you
should look at secure coding practices
and
should understand how those practices
are to be implemented in a software
development lifecycle risk management is
a must at this point in time you need to
identify threats you need to identify
how those threats are posing a risk to
the organization your risk management
skills how you're going to calculate
that risk and present it to the
management not on the next scale not
only firewalls but ids/ips s any
security controls that you can implement
including identity access and management
knowing your operating systems is a must
Windows Linux may be Mac the various
flavors of Linux operating systems and
understanding of encryption let's see
how the public key infrastructure works
what is a private key what is a public
key
symmetric and asymmetric encryption at
all of those details is something that
you should know work experience a
minimum around five to ten years of
professional experience after which you
can be eligible for IT security
consultants job role salaries could vary
from 80,000 to 86,000 u.s. dollars and 5
lakhs to 19 lakhs in Indian rupees then
we have the security systems
administrator job profile this is the
systems administrator from a security
perspective so so you're not going to be
an administrator from administrators
perspective such as administering
Windows or Linux operating systems or
the deployments but you would be
responsible for the security of these
operating systems and creating a secure
environment for the internal consumption
of the organization so as a secure
security systems administrator your job
role would be to administrate let's say
firewalls or the security of certain
switches routers or data traffic or you
going to analyze data traffic or you
going to create rules of which protocols
are allowed to pass through the firewall
and which protocol should be blocked the
requirements again educational wise you
should be a graduate in computer science
or IT security conscious security plus
CH CC and BCC na these are the
certifications that you want to look at
to become a system administrator skills
computers networks is a must so
networking skills understanding of how
SPF PGP protocols work maybe even wipe
so s IP protocol comes into the picture
here understanding that tcp/ip and the
OSI layer how these function at what
layer which protocol works how these
protocols translate into each other and
how the data packet is transmitted
firewalls any security controls and your
operate
systems work experience around four to
seven years of experience in the network
field would allow you to be eligible for
our systems security administrator
profile salary here could be around one
hundred thousand two hundred and ten
thousand and in India it would be around
two lakhs to 9 lakh Indian rupees then
you have the IT security engineer now
the IT security engineer would be a job
role where you are run you are a part of
the security operation center and there
are incidents that come on in daily talk
for the organization which you are going
to investigate and you're going to try
to resolve those incidents so again
graduate in computer science or an IT
security graduation would be required CH
CC and P CCNA or security plus these are
the certifications that you want to look
at problem-solving skills
that's a must because you're going to be
solving those problems on a day to day
basis and you will have certain time
frames that you have to adhere to
computer languages that's if you are
going to be an application security
engineer as well where you want to debug
some problems later on to analyze what
the root cause was and then try to
translate that into and try to create a
resolution based on that analysis
support skills because you're going to
support the day-to-day activity of the
organization so whenever there is an
incident you will be the person would be
called you're going to support these
individuals who have faced these
incidents and you're going to resolve
this problems for them if the
organization is using a cloud cloud
knowledge would be required for example
there there was an incident that
happened on office 365 and you are
called in to analyze and collect logs
from those particular deployments so
your understanding of cloud could help
you at that point in time
networking obviously yes because again
like I said network is the way we're
going to communicate on the intranet and
the internet so those skills would be
required across all IT job profiles in
the security field work experience you
should know security control experience
in securing cloud maybe I am ITIL or iti
and the information technology
infrastructure library certification
would be something that you want to look
at because that talks about incident
management problem management and change
management which is something that you'd
be doing on a daily basis as a security
engineer salaries would vary from one
hundred and six thousand two hundred and
twenty nine thousand US dollars or three
lakhs to ten lakhs
Indian rupees then we have a penetration
testers profile now this is complete
technical this is where you are an
ethical hacker so you're going to craft
exploits you're going to create those
attacks and you're going to try and
figure out if those attacks can be
successful against an organization and
if yes you're going to create those
reports and send it to your manager so
it's a complete hands-on role complete
technical role and this is very your
knowledge about anything and everything
that is technical in the computer field
is a must so again a graduate degree in
information technology or cyber security
CH security plus an LPD
now see it's certified ethical hacker or
security plus these are base lines where
penetration testing is taught
so these courses basically talk about
ethical hacking what are the
requirements of ethical hacker how
you're going to utilize these tools and
how you're going to create those attacks
so these are hands-on certifications
which teach you how these attacks work
how to recreate those attacks yourselves
and what to expect out of those attacks
LPT or the license penetration tester is
an advanced certification which comes
after the ECAC course EC comes a
security analyst course so this as it as
the name says it's a license from EC
Council which use your certificate to
showcase that you have the required
skills to become a penetration tester
your skills problem-solving scripting
languages would be 100% necessary at
this point in time because you're going
to create your own attacks so you may
have a requirement where you have to
create your own PowerShell script to
create an attack or a bash script or
maybe writing an exploit in Metasploit
in Ruby language knowledge of operating
systems and software so how applications
work what is the application programming
interface what is a common gateway
interface how do they transmit data how
do they handle data how do applications
talk to each other
how do applications talk to a database
and vice versa all of those requirements
come into the picture networking
protocols of course networking like I
said across all job profiles in IT
security work experience two to four
years of experience in security with
practice and penetration testing so two
to four years as a penetration tester
now the question is if you don't have
experience then how do you become a
penetration tester so there is a lot of
bounty programs that where you can
enroll and you can do it as a freelancer
to get whole new skills and when you get
those bounties against your name you can
use them as experience in your profiles
which would be counted against those two
to four years of experience as a
penetration tester again salaries would
be from fifty thousand five hundred USD
to one hundred thousand in Indian rupees
it would be around three and a half
lakhs to 12 lakhs per annum so these are
the job rules in cyber security are
please post your comments if you have
any questions or if you have any
feedback about whatever we have
discussed so far in the comment section
below and with that I thank you for
going through this video and your
comments and your feedback will be most
welcome thank you hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos Turner DUP and get
certified
click here